>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> David Mao: OK.
Well, good afternoon again.
My name is David Mao.
And I was supposed to be welcoming
the new ambassador from Mexico
to the United States, but he has
been detained across the street.
And as we at the Library of
Congress know, Congress comes first.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm told that he will
be joining us momentarily.
So we'll go ahead and get started,
and if Ambassador Sada
Solana is able to join us,
he will at the end of the program.
It's my pleasure, of
course, to have the ability
to celebrate something here
at the Library of Congress.
And, you know, we celebrate
things all the time.
But this is particularly significant
because so many people have
worked so hard on this.
We're here to celebrate, of
course, the Spanish language version
of a very important tool
of the Library of Congress,
and that is the website
that talks about Mexico
and its relationship
with the United States.
We've had that information
available for quite some time
and we've been working even harder
to make it available in Spanish.
And so that's what we're here
for today, and I'm very excited
that we're able to do that.
I think all of you know here
what's available on the website.
It includes a lot of
primary source information
from the Library's collections,
whether it be prints or photographs,
manuscripts, pages from rare books,
things like that, all digitized.
And perhaps more importantly it
includes text and commentary to talk
about this historic period
that defined the border
between the United States and
Mexico, and really was very,
very instrumental in
defining the relationship
between our two countries early on.
And so I think it's really fantastic
that we're able to now provide
that information in Spanish.
I have to congratulate
Georgette, of course,
as the chief of the Hispanic
division for leading the team.
And where's Barbara?
I saw Barbara somewhere.
Oh, right.
Sorry. Right in front
of me, Barbara --
[ Laughter ]
-- former Mexican specialist.
And Juan Manuel and,
Tracy, where are all of you?
Oh, Tracy's over here.
And certainly I saw Everett
[assumed spelling] somewhere --
oh, there you go -- former
head of the Reading Room.
All of you working together over the
-- how long has it been, actually?
>> Eight years.
>> David Mao: Eight --
>> That we've been working together?
>> David Mao: No, no,
on this Spanish --
[ Laughter ]
-- language -- [laughs].
>> The Spanish part?
Six years.
>> David Mao: OK, six years.
So that's how long it took
with all of these people,
a couple of interns
thrown in there, of course,
and certainly collaboration
with a lot of our colleagues
at the Library -- across
the Library.
And many of you are
sitting here in the audience
to celebrate this terrific
launching.
So congratulations to all of you.
Welcome to -- all of you to
the Hispanic Reading Room.
Is there anything else
I need to say?
No, I'm delaying.
I was hoping that the
ambassador would come in --
[ Laughter ]
-- so that I could properly
introduce him, but we'll have
to save that until the end.
So let's turn it over now to
Georgette to give us a little talk
about it, and then we'll carry on.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Georgette Dorn: An ambassador's
time is never his own, as you know.
We are very honored to have you all
here in this historic Reading Room.
As you know, this is the first
foreign area reading room
of the Library of Congress,
which opened its doors in 1939,
and it's one of three
still in the same place.
The others are the Rare Book
Room and the Main Reading Room.
The Mexican Revolution was a very
important event in the history
of both Mexico and
the United States.
It changed the border, the frontera,
forever between the two countries.
And this exhibit started
as an exhibit, actually.
And then we couldn't raise enough
money for an exhibit as such.
So we decided to do a website, which
I think is much more interesting
because it's going to be here
forever on the web, and --
so people from around the world will
be able to see these unique maps,
films, photographs, manuscripts --
especially prints and photographs
from all over the area that are
here in the Library's collections.
And I want to thank very
much Barbara Tenenbaum
and Everett Larsen [assumed
spelling] and Juan Manuel Perez
who spirited this wonderful
project with Tracy North.
And so it took a lot of hard work.
And with a number of interns,
whom I shall not mention
because there're probably 20
different interns who worked
on it for -- over the years.
And the Spanish version
was very much supported
by the Mexican government
and the Embassy of Mexico.
And I will now introduce
you to Barbara Tenenbaum,
the former Mexican specialist
of the Hispanic division,
who is still a volunteer, so
we still see her all the time.
And I don't want to close
without thanking Beverly
Brennan [assumed spelling],
Sarah Duke [assumed spelling],
[inaudible] Motion Pictures and all
over the Library who've really
helped us with this exhibit.
Barbara.
[ Applause ]
>> Barbara Tenenbaum:
Good afternoon.
Thank you, David and Georgette.
For Mexicans and for
people who love Mexico,
the 10th year of every
century is a momentous event
because it commemorates both
the beginning of the movement
for independence from
Spain in 1810 and the start
of what would become the
Mexican Revolution in 1910.
Given that the Library
itself was founded in 1800,
I assumed that we would
have very few items relating
to the Independence.
So working on something concerning
the Mexican Revolution was an
obvious choice for us.
And it was a good choice,
since it turned
out that every single division
of this Library had something
about the Mexican Revolution.
It was just absolutely amazing.
It's been a long road from my
first thoughts on how the Library
of Congress could celebrate these
events from an actual exhibition
of some of the treasures
held here, to a website,
to a bilingual website; the
first assembled by the library,
assisted by a vital grant
from Mexico's Secretaria
de Relaciones Exteriores,
better known as Mexico's
Foreign Ministry.
Part of the reason the website
took a long time to complete was
that we found so much material
and with that so many surprises.
Even observing copyright
restrictions that limited us
to material published by 1924 or so,
we still found lots of treasures.
For example, who knew that President
William Howard Taft would write his
beloved wife, Nellie, after
meeting President Porfirio Diaz
for the first time --
and the last time --
that he hoped that the Mexican
president would outlive him
because he didn't want
to have to deal
with what might come after that.
>> Carlos Manuel Sada Solana: Sorry.
Sorry for interrupting.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum
>> No, no, no.
Please.
That the motion picture
division would have movies filmed
on location during the
Mexican Revolution.
Who knew that Pancho Villa
didn't have battles at night
because they were impossible
to light?
He made a contract with movie
companies so they could film him.
I mean, he was no fool.
[ Laughter ]
Who knew that the music
division would have sheet music
from the period, and
that some talented people
on staff would bring
these tunes to life?
Who knew that the manuscript
division would have original
manuscripts by Brigido Caro who left
Mexico to live first in San Antonio
and then to Los Angeles in
the manuscript division?
We have six original
plays written by him.
The site has already led
to Mexicans asking for copy
of Emilio Vazquez Gomez's La
Reeleccion Indefinida of 1890,
and we sent a copy of
the 18-paged document.
Or that a professor looking
at Chicano Theater would happily
see the works of Brigido Caro
and get very excited that
he could actually read them
in the manuscript division?
We are currently working
with El Colegio de Mexico
to establish a two-month grant so
that a Mexican student can come
to the Library and work on
the materials alluded to
and found on the website.
We hope that this will lead to
greater and greater interaction
between the Library of Congress --
the largest library in the world --
and Mexican institutions
of higher learning.
Just as it takes a village
to raise a child, so, too,
it takes many people -- and many
more because websites continue
to live, not like books -- it takes
many people to complete a website.
I would like to recognize just
a few: my chief, Georgette Dorn,
my colleagues, Dr. Everett
Larsen [assumed spelling],
Dr. Juan Manuel Perez,
and Tracy North.
Colleagues throughout the library
also helped on this project.
In particular, I'd like to recognize
Karen Moses [assumed spelling]
from the music division.
I didn't see her, so I
don't think she's here.
Jennifer Cutting [assumed spelling]
from the American Folklife Center,
Francisco Macias from
the Law Library,
and many, many, many others.
We had stellar interns
working on the project,
including Jeffrey Helm
[assumed spelling],
Fenix Paz [assumed spelling],
Cristina Torrellano [phonetic],
and many, many others.
So now it's time for you to see
the Spanish incarnation of the U.S.
and the Mexican Revolution.
So, Tracy North, you're up.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Tracy North: Thank you.
So as Dr. Tenenbaum stated,
many people have worked
on this online exhibition
over the past several years.
I came along toward the end
and have been involved just
in the final push to
launch the site.
We did launch the English version
of the redesigned site in February
of this year, and we're here today
to celebrate the launch
of the Spanish version.
Before I continue, I feel
like I have to confess
that you're not going to
be getting a live demo.
It is screenshots only.
So if you'd like to take out
your phones and follow along,
the site is optimized for mobile
viewing and looks phenomenal
on phones, iPads, all the way
up through desktop computers.
So please, after today,
go take a look at it.
You will be impressed,
I guarantee you.
So how did we make this happen?
We consulted with our
colleagues in the exhibits office.
Specifically, Betsy
Nahum-Miller and Vicki Fortuno,
who has since retired, and others.
And we've worked very closely
with the web services staff,
Bill Tellum [phonetic], Tipp
Padavong [phonetic], Laura Moiseev,
and Collen Burn [assumed spelling],
specifically, all under the guidance
of John Barton [assumed spelling]
and the Director of Collections
and Services Helena Zinkham.
So to conform to the Library's
standards, we filled in templates
for the content and the descriptions
of the 100-plus objects
in this exhibit.
Now you don't have to
look at me anymore --
[ Laughter ]
-- you can just look at the screens.
[laughs] So where do
you find a page?
Well, you can follow the Library of
Congress on Facebook or on Twitter.
You can follow our 4 Corners blog
where we highlight
international collections.
In all of these places, we have
been highlighting this Mexican
Revolution project.
And you can also visit
our website directly.
If you go to the exhibitions home
page and then click on the link
for all exhibitions, listed on
the left-hand side of the page --
and keep in mind that this
site includes all current
and past exhibitions.
So it's really true what Dr.
Dorn says, this will live
on past our lifetimes
here at the Library.
Scroll down to M, and you'll
see the link to the exhibition.
Once you arrive on the page, you're
greeted with a short introduction
and a sense of the
structure of the site.
A link to the Spanish version,
the version en Espanol,
appears on each page.
I find the site very
easy to navigate.
And like I said, I'd
like to have you join me
on a stroll through the exhibition.
First, some of the special
materials that surround the objects.
We have included a
timeline that begins
with the 1908 Creelman interview
and goes through the early 1920s.
We have a special feature
that offers an interactive map
of the tragic ten days of a revolt
in February of 1913 in Mexico City.
Now up until this point, Mexico City
itself had been excluded from a lot
of the battles of the Revolution.
Not after this.
So the way the interactive page
works, you click on a number
and it takes you down to a
blowup of that specific section
with a little more detail
about each of the events
that took place during
that tragic ten days.
As has been alluded to, we
also have made available audio
and video files related
to the Revolution.
Now, these recordings cannot be
downloaded, but they can be streamed
on your mobile device or on your PC.
So getting right into the content,
the first section describes some
of the roots of the Revolution
in Mexico as well as other events
that were happening throughout
the world around the same time,
and begins to describe
some of the relevant items
in the Library's collection.
The next section goes into Porfidio
Diaz and the Porfiriato in Mexico
and then introduces the
presidency of Francisco Madero.
Photographs, broadsides and
maps illustrate this section.
Now let's say we were live and you
were to click on the photograph
that you're looking at there,
it would actually show you
that each object in the
exhibition expands to a full size
with a description
including the metadata
about where the physical
item resides
in the vast Library of
Congress collections.
We definitely see this
site as a teaser.
Just to let people know, are you
studying the Mexican Revolution?
Here are a few things that we have.
If you want to actually see
the objects, come on in,
come take a look, you'll find
some other things as well.
After the four chronological
sections,
one section looks specifically at
the role of women in the Revolution.
This section includes portraits
of individuals as well as songs,
newspapers, journal articles,
and personal correspondence.
The section on the U.S. involvement
on the Mexican Revolution
is particularly rich.
This seems like a good place
to mention the Library's
ongoing digitization initiatives.
In fact, the papers of General
Pershing were just made available
on the Library's site.
So in going with some of the
themes you've been hearing today,
we will have the ability to add
additional content and links
to some other objects
that have been digitized,
even since we're been
working on this presentation.
So I'm not sure if you can
tell from my screen captures,
but each section is divided into
subsections with relevant objects
and explanatory text, as if you were
walking through a physical exhibit.
This is but one example of how the
objects are displayed on the site.
Now if you were to scroll down
through this particular page
and got all the way to the bottom
of the page, you would be rewarded
with an image of a letter written
by U.S. President Taft
to his brother, Charlie.
I recognize that it's not very easy
to read from where you're sitting,
but I can tell you that I've held
the object itself in my hands
in the manuscript division,
and that's what it looks like.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry, but, you know,
we're doing the best we can.
If you want to see it,
all you have to do is go
to the manuscript division, request
the box, pull out the folder,
and you can have it
in your hands, also.
Pretty special stuff.
The last section describes
the end of the Revolution
and alludes to the future of Mexico.
And it does include the Constitution
of 1917, which we have in full text
in the Diario Oficial,
published in 1917.
So the Constitution of 1917,
still enforced 100 years
later, has 137 articles.
These define citizenship, organize
a government, mandate land reform,
and enumerate basic human
rights for all Mexicans.
It's divided into ten thematic
titles and lists human rights,
national citizenship, as well
as outlining associated rights
and specifies freedoms of
foreigners residing in the country.
It establishes the government,
public service, and social welfare,
and Mexico City as the capital, of
course, with the [inaudible] Federal
as a separate entity apart
from state jurisdiction.
>> Carlos Manuel Sada
Solana: [Speaking Spanish]
[ Inaudible Speakers ]
>> Carlos Manuel Sada Solana: Well,
it seems that everybody
speaks Spanish --
[ Laughter ]
-- so perhaps I can give very
brief remarks in Spanish,
but I'll [inaudible] -- it is a
unique occasion to be here today
and to be witnessing
what is happening
with these new presentation or
new document, new information,
new possibilities to keep
discovering and learning
and understanding better
the relationship
between Mexico and
the United States.
And as I always speak, and
as I speak and been in front
of that painting of Benito Juarez,
which was given to the Library
by a former president of
Mexico, Lopez Portillo,
you understand how deep and
far way goes the relationship
between our two nations.
And by looking at some of
the pictures, I was focusing
in particular on the
Francisco Madero who was one
of the ideologists of
the Revolution of Mexico,
and he presented his plan
precisely in San Antonio.
And I'm just coming from the
Congress to having a meeting
with Joaquin Castro, who is one of
the congressmen, the twin brothers
that were born in San Antonio.
And one of them, as you
know, is a congressman
and the other one a
Secretary of House in here.
And we were talking
[inaudible] the relationship
with Mexico and the United States.
And by looking at Francisco
Madero --
I lived in San Antonio
for a while --
if you go to Mexican politics
nowadays, if you see who is one
of the top hierarchies and persons
in one of the political parties
of Mexico, it's Gustavo Madero,
which is the grandson
of Francisco Madero.
But he looks exactly like him.
[ Laughter ]
Exactly like him.
He wears the same kind of beard
and he has the same way
of combing his hair.
So --
[ Laughter ]
-- it was like I was seeing him.
And I says, oh, this
is what history's about
and this is what we learn on a
daily basis of the relationship
that exists, that's so rich
a relationship between us.
And this, no doubt, this
contribution is going
to keep helping us to understand
how deep goes this relationship.
Now in this capacity I've been on
different fronts, different parts
of the United States representing
Mexico in consulate activities.
I live close to the
border in San Antonio now.
In this capacity, my
daily job is to really --
trying to position and making people
understand how the relationship
between the two countries
goes on a daily basis.
I was today also with the Secretary
of [inaudible] of the United States.
We were discussing the
waters of the Rio Corrales,
how it affects our two
nations, and the waters
of the Rio [inaudible], Rio Grande.
So every single day there is so many
things occurring in these unique,
I would say, and multidimensional
relationship between our nations.
And I'm going to be referring to
this new contribution of the Library
of Congress in order to go deep into
learning what happened in that epic
that marks Mexico and
makes us what we are now.
And how many Mexicans came to
the United States at that time?
Your guess is as good as mine,
but it's in the millions.
And that transformed
the relationship.
So it is a crucial time and
crucial epic in the relationship
between Mexico and
the United States.
And it changed, totally, what
Mexico was and what Mexico is now.
The Constitution of
1917, it is unique.
It was the very foundations
of what the country is about.
And it is also a changing
of a regime that have lasted
with Porfirio Diaz for
more than 33 years.
And that -- this is a personal
note -- I'm being from Oaxaca,
Benito Juarez was from Oaxaca,
Porfirio Diaz was from Oaxaca.
It is not that all of
us are dictatorships.
We are --
[ Laughter ]
-- or dictators, I am sorry.
But actually, it is a part of
what some [inaudible] continued
to [inaudible] the relation of
Mexico and the United States.
And I'm going to be one of
the first users of this.
You provoke me, and --
[ Laughter ]
-- as soon as I get home,
I'm going to go internet.
More of a form of the
short notes that I have:
it is indeed a great pleasure
to be here representing Mexico.
The Spanish division has more
than 75 years maintained a very
close relationship with the Embassy
of Mexico and academic
institutions in my country.
Thanks to its commitment to the
study of history and culture
of Latin America, and
in particular Mexico,
the division has been a fundamental
source for Mexican academics.
Since our nations became
independent, Mexico and the U.S.
as neighbors have had a
very close and unique,
and could mention controversial
sometimes --
[ Laughter ]
-- [inaudible] half.
Many millions of documents
housed here have witness
to our shared vicinity
and the importance
and richness of our relation.
The leadership of Georgette
Dorn in this division is --
of course, the devotion of our
dear friend, Barbara Tenenbaum --
thank you so much -- an
expert on Mexican history --
and she received the
Aguila Azteca --
she's a recipient of
the Aguila Azteca award
that they have nourished and
deepened the ties of collaboration
between Mexican experts
and academic entities.
Also, for years the division
has recorded the voice
of the most important Mexican
writers and intellectuals,
which has broadened and enriched
the Library's Hispanic collection.
An example of that collaboration is
the Spanish version of the webpage
on the United States and
the Mexican Revolution
that we'll now learn
what's it's about,
developed with the cooperation
of my predecessors, in this case,
Ambassador [inaudible]
and Eduardo Medina-Mora,
and of course the Mexican
Cultural Institute.
Here we have the director
of the Mexican Cultural
Institute, Alberto Fierro.
Thank you for joining us.
And I would like to single out
another important contribution
by the division to the libraries
and the scholars of the world:
the Handbook of Latin American
Studies, now in its 80th year,
which we cherish in Mexico and find
indispensable for doing research.
My sincere congratulations to
the staff of the Spanish division
for having completed the
Spanish language version
of the Mexican Revolution webpage.
Felicidades, muchas gracias.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.